[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend es ist die frage die nicht
nur die betroffenen im aartal umtreibt
dass bei einem hochwasser im
hochentwickelten und vermeintlich gut
organisierten deutschland mindestens 189
menschen sterben vermutlich sogar über
200 wie konnte das geschehen
warum wurden so viele offenkundig nicht
rechtzeitig gewarnt und aus ihren
häusern geholt
warnungen des europäischen
frühwarnsystems und des deutschen
wetterdienstes hatte es ja gegeben sogar
schon tage vorher im laufe des patienten
juli wurden sie eindringlich
warum wurde daraufhin der region erst so
spät reagiert das sind fragen die
inzwischen auf staatsanwälte
beschäftigen die staatsanwaltschaft
koblenz hat bekannt gegeben dass sie
jetzt entsprechende ermittlungen
aufnimmt
susanne gelhard und julia schröter
berichten
die flutkatastrophe im a teil mit vielen
toten nun ein fall für die justiz
im fokus der ermittlungen der landrat
jürgen pföhler
es besteht der anfangsverdacht der
fahrlässigen tötung und fahrlässigen
körperverletzung durch unterlassen
auch gegen ein mitglied des krisenstabs
wird ermittelt wir sehen bereits jetzt
zureichende tatsächliche anhaltspunkte
dafür dass warnungen verspätet und
möglicherweise unzureichend an
und auch evakuierungen möglicherweise zu
spät und wiederum möglicherweise
unzureichend angeordnet waren
das landesamt für umwelt rheinland-pfalz
hatte am 14 juli schon um 11 uhr 17 mit
der zweithöchsten warnstufe 4 gewandt um
17 uhr 17 mit der höchsten war klasse
die prognostizierten pegelstände der a
ließen schlimmes erahnen
sie waren deutlich höher als alles
bisher dagewesene
bereits um 15 uhr 26 wurden 519
vorhergesagt die werte stiegen um 22 uhr
24 schließlich waren es 77
trotzdem erfolgte die ausrufung des
katastrophenfalls und damit die
teilevakuierung erst kurz nach 23 uhr
landrat müller sieht sich dafür
strafrechtlich nicht in der
verantwortung
laut staatsanwaltschaft ist er
kooperativ teilte jedoch mit dass er die
einsatzleitung delegiert hatte und sich
in der relevanten zeit weit überwiegend
nicht in der kreisverwaltung aufgehalten
habe die ministerpräsidentin will die
ermittlungen nicht kommentieren
nur so viel dass eine solche katastrophe
natürlich nicht einfach so vorbei geht
und wir mit dem wiederaufbau damit alles
erledigt haben sondern das
selbstverständlich alles überprüft
werden muss an welchen stellen ist es
gut oder vielleicht auch nicht gut genug
gelaufen das ist doch selbstverständlich
bei einer solchen katastrophe genau
überprüfen möchte die staatsanwaltschaft
auch den zeitlichen ablauf der
katastrophe denn die flut sei nicht so
extrem schnell entstanden und so schnell
durch das aatal geströmt wie zunächst
angenommen
vielmehr gehen wir mittlerweile davon
aus dass das hochwasser der schon um
etwa 17 uhr schuld erreicht hat sind
sich hat das hochwasser jedoch offenbar
erst gegen 2 uhr 30 erreicht zwischen
diesen beiden zeitlichen polen liegen
immerhin rund neun stunden innerhalb
derer sich nach allen uns bekannt
gewordenen parametern die flut lage
fortlaufend verschlechtert hat was
geschah in diesen rund neun stunden gab
es einen punkt an dem man hätte anders
agieren müssen das will die
staatsanwaltschaft jetzt prüfen
während hierzulande gerade so viele
menschen vor den trümmern ihrer häuser
stehen erleiden viele menschen in der
türkei und griechenland gerade das
gleiche schicksal nur dass ihre
existenzen nicht durch hochwasser
sondern durch feuer vernichtet werden
die zerstörungen sind schon jetzt immens
und die katastrophe hält weiter an
in den urlaubsgebieten an der türkischen
küste sind jetzt immerhin löschflugzeuge
im einsatz
in griechenland sprach regierungschef
mitsotakis von einem noch nie
dagewesenen zustand die extreme
trockenheit habe das ganze land in ein
pulverfass verwandelt dara hassanzadeh
beginnt sein bericht nördlich von athen
evakuierung im eiltempo
die polizei räumt ganze vororte im
norden von athen
die menschen lassen ihre häuser zurück
und alles was in ihnen ist es geht ums
nackte überleben
meter um meter fressen sich die flammen
durch die völlig ausgetrocknete
vegetation dazu starke winde peitschten
die flammen auf und können dem feuer
eine neue richtung geben innerhalb
weniger minuten das ist der härteste tag
für uns was die intensität der
wetterbedingungen seit zehn tagen
betrifft seit gestern nachmittag sind
neue feuer zu den vielen fronten dazu
gekommen die wir im ganzen land haben
momentan sind es 56 brände die wir
bekämpfen
griechenland sei ein pulverfass warnte
gestern der griechische premierminister
mitsotakis heute hat es sich entzündet
selbst der versuch einer autobahn als
feuer schneise zu nutzen scheiterte die
funken sprang über die fahrbahn
zwei menschen sind bereits gestorben und
der rauch belastet ganz athen das
gesundheitsministerium bittet die
bevölkerung in den wohnungen zu bleiben
die halbinsel peloponnes der tat gibt
frei was die flammen sich in der letzten
nacht genommen haben
in dem kleinen dorf las tigers stehen
nur noch die mauern der kapelle durch
die brände sind bereits tausende
menschen in griechenland obdachlos
geworden ist eine katastrophe das feuer
kam gegen mittag die winde wirbelten die
häuser sind verbrannt und viele tiere
ebenfalls hasen scharfe hunde alles mehr
als 1000 feuerwehrleute sind im einsatz
dazu unzählige freiwillige ihr kampf
gegen die flammen wie hier in kronen bei
athen wird eher ruhig und aussichtslos
wie die arbeit des sisyphus jede
weggeworfene zigarette jeder offene
grill kann ein inferno auslösen die
trockenheit die extreme hitze werden
noch weiter andauern und im norden von
athen steht unsere reporterin annette
hilsenbeck nette du hast ja heute selbst
beobachtet wieder in den vororten athens
versucht wird die feuer unter kontrolle
zu bekommen wie ist man da vorangekommen
also tatsächlich ist so dass die
schwierig die große schwierigkeit ja
dies dass es viele einzel brände sind
und die feuerwehr die einsatzkräfte
haben das nach besten kräften mit besten
kräften bekämpft vor allen dingen die
löschhubschrauber wurden massiv
eingesetzt und ge sehr konzentriert
gerade und vor allen dingen bei den
großen bränden die auf die ortschaften
drohten hin zu brennen und das hat
eigentlich auch immer gut funktioniert
also man hat die relativ zeitnah eben
dann auch gelöscht bekommen das problem
ist dass dann immer noch glutnester
bleiben können und dann innerhalb von
der nächsten halben stunde angefacht
durch diese starken winde die es heute
auch gab dann wieder anfängt zu brennen
wir sehen das auch hinter mir da fängt
es auch gerade wieder an zu brennen
nachdem die feuerwehr gerade eben schon
mal da war gibt es die befürchtung dass
das feuer auch direkt an athen also auch
bis ins stadtzentrum kommen könnte
also wir sind jetzt hier schon bei den
vororten von athen die sind auch
evakuiert worden wir haben täglich
mehrfach smsen bekommen wo wieder neue
ortsteile evakuiert wurden wo die
aufforderung kann dass diese ortsteile
evakuiert werden müssen
und natürlich ist die angst groß dass
das in die stadt rein brennen könnte
tatsächlich ist das eine ganz große
befürchtung und deswegen versucht man
diese schneisen zb die autobahn die
hierhin dient er mir ist möglichst so zu
schützen dass eben das feuer nicht
drüber springen kann so dass es eben
nicht dazu kommt dass es zu so einem
riesen flächenbrand innerhalb von der
stadt kommt aber die auswirkung der
brände wird man ja in der stadt auch im
zentrum auf die ein oder andere weise
denn auch jetzt schon merken oder also
die fein die wir die rauchpartikel
belastung ist enorm hoch das manchmal
auch beim atmen
der himmel wird sehr trüb man riecht es
auch und die regierung hat dazu
aufgefordert fenster und türen
geschlossen zu halten
tatsächlich ist es auch so dass
natürlich auch der strom
die stromversorgung irgendwie nicht
vollständig mehr gewährleistet es sind
mehrere relaisstationen hier beschädigt
worden gerade ihrem umkreis und das
heißt dass der das gesamte stromnetz
natürlich dadurch noch mehr belastet ist
die energieversorger haben deswegen
teile immer wieder abgeschaltet also
haben bestimmte gebiete eben für eine
stunde den strom abgestellt mit
vorankündigung und um dafür zu sagen
dass es nicht zu einem vollständigen
blackout kommt also dass die
stromversorgung im großraum athen
weiterhin gewährleistet ist danke schön
hätte für diese eindrücke direkt aus
athen
weitere aktuelle informationen und
videos zur lage in griechenland und auch
der türkei gibt es online auf zdf heute
und auch in den usa gibt es verheerende
brände damit beginnen jetzt die
nachrichten ein besonderes großer
waldbrand im norden kaliforniens er hat
bereits eine fläche von mehr als 1000
quadratkilometern vernichtet und breitet
sich wie die einsatzkräfte sagen
stellenweise explosionsartig aus
tausende mussten inzwischen ihre häuser
verlassen allein in dem historischen ort
greenville einer
rührend goldgräberstadt sind zuletzt
mehr als 45 gebäude niedergebrannt seit
drei wochen wütende feuer nun schon in
der region
nach mehreren dürreperioden und wenig
regen im winter sind die brände in
diesem jahr ungewöhnlich früh
ausgebrochen zur coroner lage in
deutschland
das robert koch institut stellt in
seinem wöchentlichen lagebericht fest
dass der derzeitige anstieg der inzidenz
vor allem in den altersgruppen der zehn-
bis 34-jährigen zu beobachten sei obwohl
sich diese tendenz inzwischen auch in
den altersgruppen bis 49 abzeichne
aktuell wurden innerhalb eines tages
3448 coroner neuinfektionen anders rk ii
gemeldet 994 mehr als vor einer woche
weitere 24 todesfälle im zusammenhang
mit corona wurden registriert die sieben
tage incident steigt auf jetzt 20,4 und
das robert-koch-institut hat heute
bekannt gegeben dass von sonntag an die
südfranzösischen regionen oft italien
und provence alpes côte d'azur sowie
musiker als hochrisiko gebiete
eingestuft werden mit den entsprechenden
regelungen für reiserückkehrern darunter
sind entschuldigung das hatten wir
bereits dass darunter die regionen sind
und sie jetzt zu den niederlanden die
sind nach den nach dem rückgang der
infektionszahlen dann nicht mehr hoch
risikogebiet mit ausnahme der
landesteile in übersee die
kultusministerkonferenz hat sich
deutlich für einen regelbetrieb an den
schulen nach den sommerferien und ein
präsenzstudium an den hochschulen im
wintersemester ausgesprochen
kontinuierlichen präsenzunterricht müsse
im schuljahr 2021/2022 in der
gesellschaft höchste priorität
eingeräumt werden heißt es in einem
beschluss der konferenz
die kmk präsidentin und brandenburgische
bildungsministerin ernst betonte die
voraussetzungen für den
präsenzunterricht seien gut und gänzlich
andere als vor einem jahr
mit einer schweigeminute hat hiroshima
an den ersten atombombenabwurf der
geschichte vor 76 jahren erinnert
überlebende angehörige und politiker
nahmen an der zeremonie teil
um der schätzungsweise 140.000 opfer zu
gedenken
der bürgermeister der stadt war für
einen wandel von atomare abschreckung
hin zu einem vertrauensbildenden dialog
die bitte hiroshimas in tokio während
der olympischen spiele eine
schweigeminute ab zu halten war zuvor
vom olympischen komitee abgelehnt worden
wird kabul zu halten sein als die
westlichen soldaten aus afghanistan
abgezogen darunter auch die truppen der
bundeswehr war eigentlich jedem im land
klar dass die taliban darauf nur
gewartet haben und vorrücken würden und
dass sie auch in die hauptstadt wollen
in dem moment noch die afghanische
regierung sitzt wer weiß wie lange noch
eine provinzhauptstadt haben die taliban
bereits erobert und belagern
mittlerweile auch größeren
ballungszentren diese woche griffen sie
in kabul das haus des
verteidigungsministers an heute töteten
sie dort den regierungssprecher ihre
absichten sind klar und wer wüsste das
besser als die menschen in afghanistan
sie wissen aus der vergangenheit was es
für ihr leben bedeuten wird wenn die
taliban wieder an die macht kommen
ganz rein eigendorf berichtet für uns
aus kabul
sie alle wollen tickets kaufen für sich
und ihre familien ihr ziel mit dem bus
von kabul nach herat an die iranische
grenze die busse viele ausgediente
fahrzeuge aus europa sind ausgebucht
immer mehr afghanen machen sich auf den
weg ins nachbarland iran
von dort aus dann weiter in die türkei
mit viel glück sogar bis nach europa
familie hussaini die wichtigsten dinge
ein vier taschen alles was geblieben ist
haus und möbel mussten sie verkaufen
wenn die taliban zurückkommen ist unsere
familie bedroht sie werden mir meine
tochter wegnehmen oder meiner frau
gewalt antun
das ist das was ich fürchte
hals über kopf haben sie ihr zuhause in
masar i scharif im norden afghanistans
vor sechs tagen verlassen
bei verwandten in kabul haben sie
vorläufig zuflucht gefunden
doch hier können und wollen sie nicht
bleiben so viele tränen sind geflossen
in den vergangenen tagen was man weint
bis jetzt wenn sie ihren eltern beim
packen zusieht
ich musste alle meine freunde
zurücklassen
ich fühle mich sehr alleine seitdem wir
hingekommen sind die größte gefahr liegt
noch vor ihnen die grenze in den iran
müssen sie illegal überqueren
ich habe alles aufgegeben denn ich denke
an die zukunft meiner drei kinder
zumindest kann ich sie lebend hier
wegbringen und vielleicht haben wir dann
ein besseres leben dort die angst vor
gräueltaten die die taliban überall
begehen wo sie die kontrolle übernehmen
treibt immer mehr familien in die flucht
dass besonders frauen und mädchen
gefährdet sind davon berichten auch
afghanische menschenrechtler in der
provinz balkh haben sie ein mädchen
erschossen weil sie zu kurze kleider
trug sie haben eine schwangere frau
getötet
am nächsten morgen abschied von den
verwandten die den koran über ihre köpfe
halten eine alte tradition so sollen sie
vor den gefahren geschützt werden die
vor ihnen liegen ein paar
kleidungsstücke ein wenig essen mehr
können sie nicht mitnehmen
es muss reichen für die nächsten tage
und dann die letzte fahrt durch kabul in
den westen der stadt überall auf dem
parkplatz des busbahnhofes wartende
menschen angst trauer verzweiflung ist
zu spüren es sind vor allem junge männer
die sich auf die reise machen der bus
der die usa nicht an die grenze bringen
soll ist überfüllt
es ist einer der wenigen wege raus aus
afghanistan
über iran in die türkei von dort aus
nach europa
14 stunden fahrt liegen noch vor ihnen
begleitet von angst denn auch auf der
strecke wird in diesen tagen gekämpft
dass taliban kämpfer sie unterwegs
anhalten könnten ist jetzt ihre größte
sorge
besonders große angst haben all jene
afghanen die in der eine der anderen
form mit den ausländischen truppen
zusammen gearbeitet haben
vom tellerwäscher bis zum dolmetscher
auch die bundeswehr war arbeitgeber ohne
die sogenannten ortskräfte kommt man als
ausländische druck von einem fremden
land auch gar nicht aus wie weit
deutschland diese leute mit dem abzug im
stich lässt hat ja schon für politische
debatten gesorgt über ihr schicksal
führt die bundesregierung nun offenbar
direkte gespräche mit den taliban
nach zdf informationen gab es bereits
diskrete treffen an einem einschlägigen
ort darüber berichtet andreas kienast
es gehört zu den unfassbarkeit des
konflikts in afghanistan das wäre die
taliban sprechen will diese grausame
prügelnde bande in einem wolkenkratzer
metropole reisen muss in den luxushotels
von doha im golfstaat katar tauchen sie
regelmäßig auf die anführer die
verhandlungsführer der gefürchteten
terrorgruppe die vertreter des steinzeit
islam machen termine im business center
vergangenen samstag trifft der deutsche
afghanistan-beauftragte jasper weg den
europa- chef der taliban abdul basit es
ist nicht das erste treffen in doha aber
eines der wenigen das bekannt wird
deutschland reagiert auf die
machtverschiebung in afghanistan
dem muss man sich an der politik
anpassen man redet ja meistens nicht
unbedingt mit freunden sondern
konflikten mit feinden und da sind die
sind die taliban und muss jetzt hoffen
dass die bereits sind auch kompromisse
einzugehen die sofa taliban scheinen
bereit sie überraschen die deutschen als
sie nach dem treffen diesen tweets
senden das islamische emirat afghanistan
setzt sich für die sicherheit und den
schutz von entwicklungsprojekten und
deren mitarbeitern ein gemeint die
tausenden ortskräfte die gerade um ihr
leben fürchten und teils verzweifelt
versuchen nach deutsch
zu fliehen nur wenige haben es bisher
geschafft
wer glaubt dass die taliban
verlässlicher vertragspartner und
gesprächspartner sind und damit das
leben unserer ehemaligen angestellten in
deren hände legt der sollte sich
anschauen was die ortskräfte anderer
nationen in den letzten tagen erleiden
mussten das wurden schon welche
umgebracht das steht unseren dann
wahrscheinlich auch bevor kann man
gespräche führen mit terroristen 2014
muss präsident obama entscheiden was aus
den us soldaten bowe bergdahl wird den
die taliban als geisel halten obama
verhandelt und lässt für den einen
amerikaner fünf taliban aus guantanamo
frei einer von ihnen heißt musik und
sitzt am vergangenen samstag dem
vertreter der bundesregierung gegenüber
es ist real diplomatie seit ihrer
freilassung gehören die sogenannten
taliban 5 zu den berüchtigtsten aber
auch zu den einflussreichsten
terroristen
sie haben beim feind im knast gesessen
und haben das dort überlebt und sind bei
ihren positionen geblieben deswegen
haben den großen einfluss sind die
sicherheitsgarantien aus doha in
afghanistan etwas wert längst
kontrollieren die taliban nicht mehr all
ihre kämpfer nicht nur die deutschen
diplomaten zweifeln
die taliban haben versprochen die
frauenrechte einzuhalten wir sehen
gerade in den gebieten die sie erobern
dass es nicht passiert sie haben
versprochen den internationalen
terrorismus abzuschwören das ist nicht
passiert die gespräche die mit der
taliban geführt werden können sinnvoll
sein weil gespräche immer sinnvoll sein
können aber ich glaube den taliban kein
wort die deutschen diplomaten finden es
elend mühsam und nur begrenzt sinnvoll
mit den taliban zu reden aber besser als
es nicht zu tun
und jetzt nochmal heinz zunächst mit
meldungen für deutschen wirtschaft der
heute gab es neuigkeiten aus der
deutschen medienbranche und zwar zur rtl
mediengruppe und dem verlagshaus gruner
und jahr
stefanie bareth was städte an ja es
entsteht ein neuer europäischer
medienriese der den us-giganten netflix
und amazon die stirn bieten will dazu
kaufte der kölner fernsehsender rtl de
traditionsreichen hamburger
zeitschriftenverlag gruner & jahr eine
zäsur auch in der deutschen verlags
geschichte unter dem erst am mittwoch
mit 80 jahren verstorbenen langjährigen
verlagschefs gerd schulte hillen balkon
antja zum größten zeitschriftenverlag
europas aufgestiegen und nun endet nach
fünf jahrzehnten dessen publizistische
eigenständigkeit die tochter des
bertelsmann-konzerns gruner & jahr
bekannt durch titel wie stern geo
brigitte oder gala verschmilzt zum
ersten januar mit rtl deutschland und
seinen tv- und streaming aktivitäten das
kartellamt muss nicht zustimmen weil
auch rtl und gruner & jahr bereits zu
bertelsmann gehören auch anleger
signalisierten zustimmung zu dem 230
millionen euro deal aktien der
börsennotierten rtl mediengruppe legten
heute im sdax um gut 7 prozent zu die
fusion folgt dem trend der medienhäuser
weltweit plattformen und inhalte zu
verzahnen und zu bündeln
auch kosten lassen sich senken 100
millionen euro will rtl pro jahr
einsparen
was das für die beschäftigten konkret
bedeutet noch offen auch wer neuer chef
wird stephanie beckert vielen dank gut
eine woche nach verschiedenen
rettungsaktionen im mittelmeer darauf
die swatch 3 jetzt in einem
italienischen hafen einfahren
257 menschen hatte die deutsche
hilfsorganisation gerettet sie sind
jetzt auf dem weg nach sizilien
andere schiffe müssen weiter auf eine
genehmigung warten die auch schon bei
king hat aktuell 550 geflüchtete an bord
einige seien krank die lage werde
täglich schlimmer erklärt die
hilfsorganisation sos méditerranée es
ist wahrlich nicht so als würde man sich
in berlin oder potsdam nicht gerne an
die zeit der hohenzollern erinnern
preußens gloria wurde ja gerade erst
wieder zu neuem glanz verholfen mit dem
nachgebauten stadt schluss in stein
gehauene erinnerungskultur sozusagen die
zelebrierte preußen begeisterung hört
allerdings schlagartig auf wenn es ums
geld geht der streit um die schätze der
hut sonne zieht sich seit jahren und
wirkte zuletzt immer unversöhnlicher
auf der einen seite stehen in berlin
brandenburg und der bund auf der anderen
seite der ururenkel des letzten
deutschen kaisers
es geht um kunstschätze um
entschädigungszahlungen und umdeutung so
halten
zu dem konflikt gibt es ein neues buch
und erstmals hat sich georg friedrich
prinz von preußen ausführlich im tv
geäußert
tita von hardenberg und stephanie bürger
berichten stolz ragt die burg
hohenzollern über hechingen entschlossen
ist der burgherr und familien chef
denn seit jahren führt er einen
erbitterten erbstreit mit bund und
ländern die mühsamen versuche sich
außergerichtlich zu einigen sind
allesamt gescheitert die justiz muss
entscheiden
wie geht es vor allem darum einmal und
zwar ein für alle mal zu klären wie die
eigentumsverhältnisse sind
es geht um die schätze seiner vorfahren
und bilder wandteppiche porzellan antike
möbel und skulpturen die nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg von den sowjets
enteignet wurden
vieles davon wird in verschiedenen
museen in berlin und brandenburg gezeigt
der prinz will das familienerbe zurück
doch laut ausgleichsleistungsgesetz kann
es nur zurückgaben kommen wenn die
familie den griff der nazis nach der
macht nicht begünstigt hat die rolle der
hohenzollern ist dabei alles andere als
ruhmreich wie lothar macht dann in
seinem neuen buch der kronprinz und die
nazis eindrucksvoll belegt der sohn des
letzten deutschen kaisers wollte
mithilfe hitlers die monarchie wieder
errichten will ems nähe zum
nationalsozialismus und insbesondere zu
hitler war besonders eklatant 1931 32
da gab es so etwas wie eine
kollaboration zwischen dem gewesenen
kronprinzen des zweiten und dem
möchtegern führer des dritten reiches
diese beziehung war heikel und aus
historisch kritischer sicht kann man
auch sagen verwerflich als rückblickend
betrachtet kann man durchaus sagen dass
die ns zeit durchaus einen moralischen
tiefpunkt meiner familiengeschichte
markiert
auch nach der machtergreifung hält
wilhelm zu hitler
jetzt verspürt wilhelm auf einmal das
gefühl sich hüten sich augen zu müssen
und er tut das indem er sich selber
gleichsam zum royalen aushängeschild des
dritten reiches macht und die
machtergreifung hitlers nach außen
legitimiert vor allen dingen auch ins
ausland hinein hat der kronprinz also
die machtübernahme der nazis begünstigt
hat er so der juristische ausdruck dabei
erheblichen vorschub geleistet
ich bezweifle dass das gericht im sinne
der hohenzollern urteilen wird
aber ich will dem auf gar keinen fall
vorweg greifen sondern ich sage nochmal
wie historiker haben die aufgabe so
einer urteilsfindung zuzuarbeiten sollte
den 90er jahren wird um das erbe der
hohenzollern gestritten
die zeit ist reif für einen
schlussstrich nach den ziehen ihr gleich
zumindest für unsere sendung aber nicht
ohne den hinweis auf die ausführliche
doku zu dem thema die morgen abend um 19
und 20 bei 3sat ausgestrahlt wird und
unter dem titel des kaisers schätze vor
gericht auch in der mediathek zu finden
ist und um 0.30 gibt es dann die nächste
heute express
[Musik]
guten abend und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter der weltklimarat veröffentlichte
am montag teil eins seines neuen
berichts im mittelpunkt stehen die
klimarisiken die verheerenden
überschwemmungen im juli die extreme
hitze in nordamerika und im
mittelmeerraum zeigen dass der globale
temperaturanstieg bereits jetzt folgen
hat die erhitzung begünstigt
extremwetterlagen die erhitzung des
planeten führt einerseits zu trockenheit
und dürren andererseits wenn es regnet
dann stärker denn mit jedem grad wärmer
kann die luft 7 prozent mehr
feuchtigkeit aufnehmen bei hitze
verdunstet meerwasser
die atmosphäre wird also immer feuchter
bei einer entsprechenden wetterlage mit
langsam ziehen denn wetter systemen kann
so mehr regen auf einmal fallen und als
starkregen zu fatalen überschwemmungen
führen
starkregen und überflutungen sind
durchaus im laufe dieses wochenendes
auch möglich zumindest in der
alpenregion denn ein neues tief erreicht
uns im reigen dieser tief seit gut einer
woche vor allem die alpenregion unter
süden deutschlands bekommt hier nochmal
kräftig regen und teilweise kräftige
starke gewitter in der nacht ziehen die
gewitter im norden ab dort bis 15 grad
ansonsten im westen da kommt neuer regen
auf nach osten hin sind zehn grad und
simon im tagesverlauf kräftige teils
unwetterartige gewitter im norden
genauso im süden hier auch größerer
hagel möglich bei temperaturen bis 27
grad im osten und 19 grad richtung eifel
am sonntag noch schauer und das bei 24
grad ab montag ruhiger und sonniger ein
schöner abend